So Lou,
maybe tell us about your journey in early
Korea in corporate and why you mix a
decision to jump. So yeah. So, hi
everyone. I'm so happy to be here.
Um, last time I was here, I was in my
role as a mentor for Google Launchpad,
so I'm very excited to be back,
um,
to give you a little bit of background
about my past and professional life.
Um, so as shelter and I'm
trying to ease and um,
and when you grow up as a Chinese child,
you have a lot of expectations, you know,
from your family at that you
need to fulfill, to have,
um, you know, a good life,
um, or to be deemed successful. So my
parents always wanted to meet to Amino,
be go either into business or into
law or into, uh, into medicine.
Right. And, um, so I chose business
and the business called in Germany.
So I was born in China and
then grew up in Germany,
but all my education in Germany
went to business school.
I'm in Germany on star with Mckinsey
in Munich almost 10 years ago,
nine years ago,
Asian genes.
And, um, and yeah, so I started
with working with Mckinsey,
then moved onto drunk,
um, P and g and, um,
work in Switzerland in brand
management and marketing.
And I've done that for about five,
four or five years in total.
And then I sort of jumped,
uh, and uh, you know,
just kind of became my own
person, if that makes sense. Um,
kind of embarked on this part on the,
of,
of being an entrepreneur and I'm trying
to find out what I want to do on my own.
And the reason for that,
um,
to lots of the question actually is I
don't think you ever actually leave a
company. I think you leave
a manager think about that.
Um, and in my case, you know,
it was kind of, um, you know, I,
I had difficulties with a
buzzer was reporting to. Um,
I also saw that he had difficulty,
so boss that he was reporting to.
So if you can all think about the whole
sort of reporting chain, it just doesn't,
but it basically work out and he was like,
oh my God, this is a dead end. And, uh,
you know,
I was,
it was not possible basically for me
to maneuver in any way in that sort of
situation.
And I just basically had to leave the
company to kind of like find something new
and I as I thought, okay, I'm,
you know, I need to remove myself.
I'll just situation too.
I want to join another corporate or do I
take the opportunity to do something on
my own. And uh, that
was five years ago, um,
and I decided to do something on my
own because I'm one of these people who
think I can do things better
than other papers and the, yeah.
So I'm back on, on that journey. Yeah.
Do you ever wish you could like
maybe quit earlier or like Lucy said,
exactly. Good timing for you
to do so. I think it was the,
it was the right time, I think.
I don't think there's ever, like,
I suppose I'm the best time to leave
a job. Right. You feel it. I mean,
you know, when you offer
straight it enough and in my
case, you know, you'll do it,
or if there's a big enough other
opportunity, um, that lures you in,
then you'll do it. Right. I think, um,
every decision that you know, people make,
then, you know, it's, it's kind of
like if it's comes from the heart,
it's kind of like you're
fully like behind it,
then it is the the right time for you.
Right.
And for me it was definitely the
right time. I don't think, um,
I should have done it earlier or later.
So I don't regret that.
I sort of trumped, um, you
know, five years ago. Um,
I think what I would say though
is because I was in Switzerland,
I was actually in Germany as an expert
and then I'll move back to Switzerland
and it was,
I was not really part of the
entrepreneurial ecosystem
because there was none.
Um, I think knowing that, you know,
sort of being in London and
having so many things around you,
I think it's definitely helpful to immerse
herself even while you're employed in
these activities. I mean we, you know, run
a lot of things also over the weekends,
events and all of that. So I think
that's one thing I would have. Um,
I wished I would have had, but I
didn't hide it, I think at the time.
So there was no choice.
Cool. And after you create,
do naturally directly go
to entrepreneurship or you
take some time to figure out
what you want to do. And how
long did that take? So, I mean,
I left with the vision to
do something on my own.
I didn't know what I want to
do. Um, I just, I suppose,
wanted to do something I love, which is
my strength and, uh, do something that,
you know, I'm passionate
about and I love. Right.
And I think that's what a lot of people
think about when this of, you know,
quit a job. And, um, and then it's
about actually sort of finding,
finding out whether the idea that you
have is a viable business or can be a
viable business. And it's also a
business that you want to actually build.
Because, you know, if you're
working for a big company,
you have all the infrastructure, you
know, that, that you can dream of, right?
I mean,
you know,
buildings and food and the assistants
and telephones and all of these things
that you have to take off
yourself and your work for
you, for yourself. Right? And,
and people find out that you know,
you,
you like certain things or you are
better at certain things than others.
And uh,
so before I started blooming founders,
I had two other companies which I run by
myself also almost as a one woman show.
And I learned through that process.
I took that for about three years,
was two and a half years,
um,
that I don't want to build a company
that just has me as one person,
right? Because obviously you can trade
your time for money and then you know,
you can just kind of consult
on in a capacity and you know,
you can pay your rent, you can pay
your expenses. And that's kind of it.
But I just realized by doing that, that
after a while that I had, you know,
the ambition or this, you know,
I wasn't satisfied myself,
so I wanted to build something bigger
and more sustainable with more impact and
uh, that I couldn't have known in
the beginning. It's kind of, I think,
you know, if you're, you know,
taking the leap and then trying
to find out what you want to do,
I think it's a very, very natural
that you're doing different things,
trying different projects and find out
what works for you and what doesn't work
for you. Um, yeah, so it takes time. Okay.
And how does a book idea, Kamala, before
you answer, I just wanted to ask, um,
outings and question,
how many of you guys do right hand writing
letters to anyone around the world?
Just hands out of your,
she'll still do that
to families. To friends? Yeah. Nice. Um,
we'll keep a journal Journal,
like how many people write
to themselves a bit more.
I wonder like do they write to me
in English or in your mother tongue?
Like native language? It's quite
intimate to write a letter to someone.
So how does the idea come around for you?
So the book idea is kind of,
it was one of the first project I
released for those of under my new company
blooming founders. I started completely,
I mean, you know, sort of from scratch,
the idea was to kind of
build an infrastructure for
female founders because as I
was out there doing stuff on my own,
I realized that a lot of other women
are out there doing stuff on the,
on their own. And then if you're in the
startup ecosystem, you'll see no women.
So you kind of like cried to square up
like what's happening here. Right. And,
and it seems to me that there's a
lot of women around, but you know,
there's no infrastructure that they,
they go to apparently.
And I didn't know why that was
happening. So I started, um, uh,
you know, running events, bringing women
together that are entrepreneurial, uh,
inviting female founders,
speakers and you know,
sort of doing talks and it's exactly
what, what you are doing, um,
with 90% women and the other.
Then I actually,
I'm so glad that we have a lot
of guys in here. I'm really,
really good because obviously, you know,
the title was there a female founders,
so you know, wasn't
expected. So yay guys. Um,
so coming back to, to the, the,
the, the story. Um, so yeah,
so I started doing events and at this
event you obviously network and after,
after the event and um,
you find out over time that you know,
that there are no role models,
are very little few role models that
women have in entrepreneurship that the
media talks about the typical
sort of people such as Elon mass,
such as Mark Zuckerberg,
such as, you know,
Larry Page and all of these
people are all great people,
but there are not us. Like
it's just different, you know,
it's not the same.
And um,
and this book came about from my view of,
I think there's so many
amazing women out there,
cause I've had them speak
at my events that, you know,
we didn't need to share more content
and we also need to share more authentic
content. Um, not me going
out and interviewing people,
which I could have done, but another train
journal, I don't even know what to ask.
Basically. I can answer
questions, but you know, um,
so that's why I came up with the idea
of writing a letter because I think it's
kind of, it's quite a powerful tool.
Yeah. Um, and also it digs out, you know,
pass it insights from those entrepreneurs
that they probably would have never
been prompted by a journalist.
Right. Because who knows
what's in your head. Right.
So, yeah. So that's the long
story to how this came about.
And when you collecting all this success,
six different letters
from the female founders,
is there any particular one like you,
like most impress you
the most or something?
You never expect it as a question?
Ask a lot.
So there are 66 letter in that
book, so there's quite a few, um,
amazing women.
And so they have that,
that got featured and I have several
favorites was different reasons.
And I think, you know, people that
are just super practical and a,
and just kind of like, you know, just when
you read this, you go, oh my God, you the,
of course, you know, like should
I should do this, you know,
and then people that are a
bit more reflective and uh,
and it takes a bit longer to process
basically. And sometimes, you know,
I mean even I had to like read,
I mean I had to read cause
I edited the whole thing,
but I had to read letters several times
to, and I wanna understand what, what,
you know, what's behind. And,
uh, so yes, I mean I do have my,
my favorite letters, um, for
different reasons I think. And um,
if you probably sort of,
I mean I can probably say like
the first one of each chapter,
I have three larger sections in the book.
Probably the first one that I put is,
was kind of like one of the favorites.
And the last one is quite powerful
as well actually. Yeah. Cool.
Can't wait to read the whole book. I
think you guys probably thinking the same.
Um, and when you, when
you funding your business,
do you find this at wise give you,
um, good reason to hold down to, uh,
have you ever experienced
some of the failures or, um,
time and how do you cope with the yeah,
I think that his business reality, right?
I mean, if anybody thinks that, you
know, when you started your own business,
there's going to be eight to be like,
forget it. He's not going to happen.
So I mean, there's naturally up and downs
and, um, and then, you know, I mean,
I think sort of rooting
all of these articles and
letters. I think there's just,
you know, a lot of things that, that
is very real. And I think, you know,
just one of the things,
I mean there's just springs to mind,
but don't work with idiots. Yeah.
I mean, nobody tells you that,
but don't work with idiots. Very
simple. And, and it's, you know,
I say it's simple,
but it's actually not,
because sometimes you aren't in situations
where you have to work with people
that you actually don't like, for
example. And then, you know, it's,
it can drag a lot of energy and time out
of view. Um, and sometimes, you know,
like the boldest move you can actually
make this actually stop working with
these people, even if you have
to say no to money. Right. Um,
and cash flow is obviously
important, um, always. Um,
but sometimes it's just very deliberating
not, not to work with certain people.
Um, and, uh,
and I know that from the community and
obviously I produced the book for the
blooming founders community.
I know that some people have it next to
their bedside table and then, you know,
when they have like a shitty day, then
you know, oh, can I swear actually,
I don't know.
I'm the one they had like a bad day.
They will sort of dip into the book and
then they would sort of be motivated
again and said, etc. Um,
because you know, life happens.
That's true. Um, so when you,
on your entrepreneurial journey,
there's, do you have mentors?
Do you have like good mentor that mentor?
And how do you know at that time that's
a, it was for you. How do you know it?
So I think, I believe, I
mean, if you don't know,
I think it's good to just type this into
a lot of a pin, different opinions. Um,
and then you had to just make yourself
like make up your mind yourself.
Basically you have what you listened
to and, and just aligned with your gut.
Like who do you trust most? Right? And you
know, cause most of the time you asked,
I mean,
don't listen to people who tell you
something and you actually find out that
I've never done it
themselves. Right? I mean,
we know too many of those people and
there's a lot of mentors and advisors also
in the startup world that have never
done anything themselves, but then they,
you know, are going around and
advising people. Right. And, um,
um, so that, be careful about, um,
and over time I think, you know,
the good mentors and advisors, they would
actually sort of follow up with you,
um, because they like you and
they really want to support you.
So with most of my current mentors,
I wouldn't even call them mentors because
we almost became friends. Right? I mean,
I have everyone on whatsapp and if I
have any questions basically, right.
I just basically ping them a
message and then, you know,
I see what they say and then
I think, oh, this makes sense.
This doesn't make sense. Or, you
know, and then I just move on. Cool.
Um, I think I raised a research or
another interview date. There's,
in UK there's around 75%
of the female founder.
They're also solo founders, so they don't
have cofounder and all by themselves.
Um,
what do you think can be done to change
the reality or what caused that and what
things we can do?
So I think the reason expands is probably
not that easy to explain. I mean,
there's multitudes of, of of things.
I mean there's research, for example,
that women in business and in general
have a smaller network but a deeper
network and men and business have a
water network and more shallow network,
which means that they know the space,
the more people.
And then societal lead also men tend
to not shy away from is picking up the
phone and call up a mate to ask them
a favor or to ask him to do something.
Whereas women tend not to
do that basically because
they're aware it's risky and
I don't really want to drag another friend
into like the whole thing before they
are 100% certain. It's perfect and
it's totally, you know, you know,
safe to do, which obviously is never
is. And um, yeah, so I think, you know,
a lot of women in the community
to me as you know, um,
our solo founders because
they choose that path of x,
y that reason could be because they were
frustrated in the previous job because
they're really passionate about,
you know, this idea that they have.
But they are,
they at that time when they had the idea,
there was nobody else around that was
similarly passionate or that they knew for
long enough to kind of be a
cofounder. Yeah. But then, you know,
sort of people venture out and then they
try to find a cofounding team and that
becomes really difficult as well because
you don't obviously know the people and
then, you know, people might take
advantage of you and all of these things.
So I think it's a multitude of reasons
why women tend to build businesses on
their own. Um, set this though,
you know, I mean, luckily
we still have, um, you know,
women founding teams,
the no mixed teams as well
that built great businesses.
But I think the overall sort
of landscape is, unfortunately,
I'm still that way and I hope through
the, you know, the work that we do.
So we recently opened,
um, the physical space,
a physical work and events
space called Bloom's London.
So it's a coworking space slash
event space slash members club.
And I think the members club element
comes through bringing the community
together. Right. I'm connecting you
with other women, um, that do, you know,
I see similar things in business
but have different businesses, um,
and you can collaborate and then,
you know,
you can form teams that
might not be sitting on the
one company but at least are
sort of like, you know,
associated in a, in a way.
So you're not working on your own.
So maybe slash lay outside the
topic, you know, incorporate,
we're always talking about what life
balance. We have yoga, we have lunch here.
Once you become an entrepreneur and
you used to be in this environment,
how do you adjust yourself and
how do you keep the balance?
I think balance is another
interesting question. I should,
I think balance is a personal choice.
Um,
I think everybody has needs to get to
know their own bodies better and you know,
understand are you a morning person?
Are you a night person? Are you,
what personality are you normal,
regular, working hours person. Um,
and what do you need in your
life basically? Right? So
when I left the corporate,
um, what I've done and I could
have wiped out my schedule,
like nine to five or whatever and also
Monday to Friday cause I had seven days
in the week. And, um, and I'm not sure
if you, you probably know like this, I'm
sure what it was, but
you know, like this, um,
there's this story about this professor
in a university and he comes up with
like these two vases and like stones and
sand and then he talks to the students
about, I think it's about time management
or something. And you put in like,
you know, the stones and
the days and then I'm sorry,
the sand into the vase and then the
stones and it doesn't fit basically,
that have overflows. And then he
puts the stones first and then, um,
the sand around it and then
everything's fits perfectly.
And I think that was the analogy around,
you know,
making sure you put the
priority. Like, you know,
like you will the priorities in check
and you know, your ducks in a row.
But I think that's what I've pretty
much done with my schedule with my time.
So I wiped everything out and I say, okay,
I need to sleep like seven hours a day.
So where do I plug that in?
I actually tend to sleep between
one and eight for example.
And I work the best actually between 10
and one cause that's like my quiet time.
Um, I proud of that in
then. You know, friends,
I see them for brunch or drinks or
whatever, like to call my mom, you know,
all of these things basically that.
Um, but somehow actually I read this,
I had a really simple lives.
I don't have that many stones to Putin,
which as a result, the rest
basically it was basic, you know,
sand for me and my businesses
stand basically. Right.
It's kind of everything else that,
that I create in my life. And, um,
and that's my definition
of work life balance,
because if there's anything
in a stolen coming right,
I mean I would visit to make,
to make that stone sort of work somehow
and just remove the sound a little bit.
Right. Um, yeah. So that's good.
Oh yeah. I'll ask one more question
and I'll open up to the floor.
The Googlers are really good with
questions. Just be prepared. Um,
so what advice would you give to
funders out there? It doesn't matter,
male or female. What do you do
say to, I would actually say like,
the advice that you find in this book
is applicable to everybody, right?
I mean it just comes from a
female perspective because
that person happens to be
a woman. Um, but, uh,
I think my general advice is to do it,
to explore whether
entrepreneurship is for you. Um,
there's literally nothing to lose.
I mean, if you think, I mean,
maybe it was a bit of money,
fine. I mean, you can, you know,
dawn another company and
or money again, right? Um,
but you know,
like the time is not lost because you
learn so much and it's so different
actually to how corporate life works.
And you also get to know
yourself actually a lot better.
So I think entrepreneurship, you know,
is a really good way to get, you know,
like too for personal development.
And, um, and you know,
some people succeed,
great, some people don't,
but then they realize actually, you
know, I don't have to build a business.
I'm actually much more happier.
Cause sometimes you don't know what you
have until you actually get rid of it
and like loser basically.
Right.
And some people actually I know are
very happy but in a job and still do,
you know what they did on the side as
a hobby basically. But then at least,
you know, you feel a lot more
comfortable and at ease that, you know,
this is how I want to design my life now.
Right. I mean it's not a constant, um,
state I would say. Yeah,
exactly. Oh yeah. Great.
So now over up to the floor,
if you have questions,
just raise your hand and I'll give you
a microphone. So we'll start from there.
Tell me about the process
of writing the book, uh,
in terms of selecting the,
the, the, the founder's Eh,
how you pitch it,
how you convinced them to separate a time
to write these really intimate later.
You gave them a deadline. Did you have
to do much chasing? Tell us a bit.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So it took me about nine months from
having the idea to actually holding the
book in my and my hands. So it's,
it's self published through Amazon.
Everybody can self publish
a book. Um, and uh,
so took me in total nine month and, um,
I started with the women that I know,
the new, uh, that I have
invited to speak at my events.
And I think the criteria was that
they had to be, you know, um,
they must have achieved something
interesting, basically insignificant.
So I had like, they had to be in business
for at least three years and a ideally,
you know,
there's many like employees or race
that much funding or have generated this
much revenue. So all
of the 66, altogether,
they've generated $1 billion
in revenue. Right. And some,
obviously more than others,
but you know, and uh, yeah.
So I leverage my own personal
network. Then I have, um,
ask them basically to kind of refer me to
other women because, you know, it's, uh,
you know,
it's a small group of four or five
pills or then people tend to know other
people. Um, I have also,
um, reached out through,
you know, the Google network,
like the accelerator networks,
a startup weekend.
So I volunteer for something or we can
organize or weekends and so we can,
as around the globe and that I utilized
after I have pretty much gotten like,
you know,
20 people like in around London and the
u s which I provide the first people you
get because it's kind of like, you
know, the, the density is there,
but I really wanted to have a global
perspective. Do you have people from,
you know, New Zealand,
China, you know, and um,
Columbia and Mexico and, and, and things.
So for that I had to use sort of like
top to other networks and started working
with amazing. That works.
So, um, you know, everybody's
like so helpful and you know,
helping you to connect. And, uh,
also my business school friends because
they are everywhere in the world now.
So from near Dubai to Indonesia to like
everyone's a bit like a high, you know,
and um, and so that's how I
have reached out. I think the,
I also tried linkedin
and just like Linkedin,
like connections and messages
that was like the least effective,
but I called a couple
third that, um, yeah.
And how we'll approach
them was actually I,
so I actually wrote a letter
myself as a example. Right.
And I gave them quiet,
um, specific. So the f um,
I suppose directions,
right?
So it started with DFMO founder cause
that's the title of the book and
everything.
Start with the female founder.
It has to be between 500
and a thousand, not, sorry,
800 and 1,500 words. So it also
communicates, it's not too long.
Yeah. You're not asking him to write
like a book, but just a letter.
And, um, and, and basically
just think about, you know,
if you were to sit down
and write a letter,
what would you advise to your
younger self or, you know,
your best friend who was starting
a business and, and, and,
or the future generation
of female founders. Right.
And I think that idea has resonated a
lot with the people that contributed,
that everybody was just so happy to
do it. And they were like, oh my God,
I always wanted to do that. It's like,
good that you're giving me the chance,
you know?
And,
and I got actually a lot of gratitude
from people because people were like,
actually,
you know,
thank you for helping me to find my
voice and my story and to tell my story
because I've never done that
before because I was never
asked because that comes
with it over Israel problem because
they were never ask. Right. Um,
so yeah. So I think somehow, I think
the idea just resonates it. Um,
pretty much everybody had a positive
response. Um, probably hotter people.
I've contacted well conduct around
like 150 people. Um, so it's lovely.
I would love to contribute, but I'm so
super busy that I just don't have time.
But you know, let me know
when it's out. And, um,
I would love to support and spreading
the word or something. Um, yeah.
Cool. So just go, do they also post it to
you like writing and stamp? No, no, no.
Oh yeah. So Google box guys. Yeah. So,
um, yeah, no, it's to be
honest, like the, the actual,
my work was really just project
management cause he was just, you know,
you quit your hit list, you contact
them, you see what they say, right.
Does everything in excel or Google sheets.
And then literally I would just ask
people to send me a Google doc. Right.
And then we would,
I would edit it in the Google doc with
them and every letter before we had like,
you know, between three to
five, sort of like rounds of,
of um, feedback and then, um, and
that's it. Right. Just sign off.
That's the text.
You copy it further and that's not good.
Thanks. Thanks for sharing your
story. Um, so you mentioned that, uh,
the letters are from sort of
a global base. Yes. So you,
you spoke to people and had contributions
from all over the world. Um,
what proportion of the letters were
from sort of the US versus Europe versus
Asia in general?
And did you notice any trends,
like themes of different
types of challenges that
people faced in North America
versus what perhaps they faced
here or, or in Apac? Okay,
so I think around, I forgot
the numbers, to be honest. Uh,
around 2020 people are
actually from the UK.
Another like 15 or so
are from the u s so like,
probably half of the book
is kind of UK, u s. Um,
and then the rest is kind of
like across the globe. Right.
And at some one I would just literally
keen on having somebody in Africa,
for example. Um, and yeah,
and I think in terms of the
advice that the people, I mean,
I also had like entrepreneurs
[inaudible] stuff in Sierra Leone,
but we're actually Americans, for example.
Right. So it's a bit, you know, um,
but I think in terms of advice,
I think it really depends more on the
type of business and the industry that
they were in. Then the actual
country. I do see business,
you know, in the, in the
agents that have like sphere,
there is more cultural
expectations, um, around, uh,
around topic of entrepreneurship because
it's not something that women do to be
honest. Um, and uh, and then in, in terms,
and it's funny cause I think the,
the girl from Latin America within
lady actually, she's a scientist,
she's like heavy, heavy
like science stuff. Um,
she kind of was, um, was
interesting because she's like,
she doing as like super serious thing.
And then like her letter was kind of
like really bubbly, like, you know,
so that's what I felt that you
and the way that she was writing,
that's the other Latin American sort
of flavor came out in a little bit. Um,
but that's just kind of like, you know,
for, from an editing perspective, um,
from a content perspective,
I would say I was surprised to see that
probably only like five to maximum 10%
of what people talk
about is actually gender.
Genderized is actually sort of about like,
oh, as a female founder, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. Like most of the things
are really just super, you know,
applicable across everything.
So I think,
and I found that quite
interesting because, you know,
I didn't give them a bit,
a more specific brief and then I shared
with you just now and people were not,
you know, um, oh my God,
I'm a female founder, I'm so
discriminated and you know,
the word is so horrible, you know,
I mean, you obviously have that,
but in the grand scheme of things,
I think probably also people just don't
want to share that back to the future
generation. Right. I think,
you know, we, we, we want to
be more positive, um, about,
about entrepreneurship. Yeah. Yeah.
As you,
as you've mentioned that we as as women,
we don't have as many role
models in terms of CEOs. Uh,
there are female out there.
I was just wondering if there were any
common topics in the book and the letters,
um,
about women feeling a bit
like the imposter syndrome
and Google sometimes they
talk about, oh my, I'm not sure if I
should be here if I deserve to be here.
So I'm just wondering with women being
CEOs if there they talked about anything
about,
I cannot believe I'm a CEO
or things like that they did.
There they do. And I think, um,
what did come out,
I think what makes a difference at women
wrote those letters is a little bit of
that, but a lot of about, um,
taking care of yourself kind of thing
and being true to yourself and not,
you know, trying to do
something just because the rest
of the world wants you to,
to do it right. So for example, I'm in
a typical startup acceleration phase.
As you know, you, you, you
know, you start a startup, you
get like, see, like, you know,
you go through an accelerator,
you get your seed funding,
you get your series a and B in
another and so forth, right? And, um,
and it requires a certain of business
to do that and actually sort of perform
against all of these metrics,
but it might not be the best business and
it might not be the best miss this for
you as well. Right? So
people pivot, right? And then
sometime it's kind of like,
you know,
am I doing the wrong thing of having
graduated from a Texas accelerator for
example, and now pivoting into
an agency for example, right?
That might be super profitable because
we were really good at what we're doing,
but isn't the high growth tech business
that people thought that we were doing
in the beginning. Right. And
I think letting go and, and,
and sort of like, you know,
sort of that type of
attachment. Um, you can, uh,
like read a little bit through, through
the book and, and also then, you know,
attached to like, it's, it's, you know,
it's very stressful obviously, um,
to just be okay with yourself to say,
okay,
you know,
I am in that game or I am in a different
game and I'm totally fine with being in
a different game. Right. And, and to the
south, the imposter syndrome thing. Um,
so that's actually in the first letter
written by a lady called Alex. Uh,
Alex on a deep latch from
hospital commentary exited
hustle couple of years ago
and now she's building her second
startup hub bill path. And um,
she has like,
one of her tips for that is when you
sort of have a important meeting,
important presentation,
you go to the bathroom,
you look into the mirror and you say,
I am the shit to yourself,
right? And then you go back
up and then it's all good.
So things like that, you know. Cool.
So what is the next
step for you from there?
So you know what the book was
literally something, I mean,
I didn't have any motives behind the
book to be honest. Right? I mean,
I published it because I've,
I felt the content was needed and then
I was engaging with the community at the
time.
So for me,
I'm obviously super happy to promote the
book all the time because I think it's,
it's valuable content, um,
to share. But, um, you know,
I'm not Simon Sinek basically.
Right? There was like, no,
like gigantic other thing that is
kind of like coming behind the book is
literally just kind of like, you know,
for the universe really. And, uh,
so my business is around building this
infrastructure for female founders. Right.
And the book is obviously one
element is one product that you can,
that you can get. And, and
the other product that, the,
the thing that I want to
scale is, um, you know,
this online to offline
sort of infrastructure that
includes the online community
where you can make connections and, um,
you know, share knowledge and experiences.
Plus then sort of seeing everybody in
real life in those coworking spaces that
I'm creating. Right. So, so that's
kind of like, you know, sort of the,
the business that I'm
looking to build and a,
at the moment we have the
first one in all street. Um,
and we're looking to kind of, you know,
then grow that and open more spaces.
And in west London,
um,
I'm actually thinking
about Bali because why not?
Who doesn't want to work in
Bali and other locations. Yeah.
We're going to do one more
question and then, yeah. Cool.
Hi Lou. Thank you for joining.
This is truly amazing.
It's something that I would dream to
publish, but I'm glad you beat me to it.
The question I have for you is for there
anyone or any founders that you reached
out to where you thought,
you know,
they might never respond and when they
did you were kind of nervous or like,
oh my God,
they actually responded
like a Sheryl Sandberg or,
yeah, it doesn't matter.
I try to [inaudible] stole sandbar
but didn't go far enough I suppose.
Um, I think, I don't know,
it's a difficult question
to answer because
yeah,
I though positive,
honestly thing that every woman who has
achieved something almost has a moral
obligation to do that.
So therefore, you know,
I think that when people responded
positively, I was like, yes, you got it.
Awesome. Let's do this. Right.
Like I wasn't me, like, hold
on, call. She accepted it.
This is so amazing. You
know, it's, I, it's fine. You
know, I mean it's, it's, um,
I think, um, yeah, because
I know in that way,
I mean I felt a bit and title,
does that make sense? And the,
in a non sort of like, oh no, I think
just got to do this kind of thing.
But I actually genuinely think that that,
you know,
successful people have a moral obligation
to, to share their knowledge with,
with the future generation.
So I was generally happy that they
got it and they didn't know they were
supporting me on, on that
journey. And, um, and I think, um,
I was also kind of, I think what I was
surprised about is actually the, the,
the surrounding support,
right.
So one thing I forgot to
mention is actually I also
had a nomination process to
find interesting,
um,
women and a lot of people actually use
that actually because sometimes you don't
know the woman yourself,
but you know,
their previous pa or the
marketing manager or you know,
is now like a female founder herself.
And then she knows me.
So she would sort of like,
you know, suggest her previous
boss and, and, and, and,
and stuff like that. So that I
actually felt, um, it was really nice,
but that got me, was like, oh, sweet,
exciting. I didn't know you were doing,
you know, so, so, yeah. Cool. Great.
So thank you Lou leaf of sharing the
experience and the book and thank you
everyone for coming and all the good
question. I hope you guys enjoy the book.
Feel free to maybe ask a Luli
afterwards for a few questions.
Sign the book if you won. So,
yeah, see you guys next time.
Thanks.